from Mike's house to you direct this is
very strange
all right well Steve did a great video
on VPNs and how to have work remotely
right and now we're all doing this so I
thought I talked also a little bit about
networking or you know a cryptographic
protocol that we often use over networks
in one of my previous videos I talked
about quantum computing and what kind of
effect if any that would have on
encryption and the answer really is that
it has quite a big effect on public key
cryptography but not that big an effect
on on symmetric cryptography you know
that's assuming we can build bigger
quantum computers sometime now what I
wanted to talk about today is a really
cool protocol that actually sees a lot
of use particularly I mean everywhere
right on lots of different operating
systems but particularly on Active
Directory as its main authentication
mechanism and that's kerb loss right II
remember kerb loss the three-headed dog
but guards ain't Hades is it so it has a
cool name we're off to a good start
curb loss is a really interesting
protocol because it's a way of managing
authentication and communication over a
network like a giant enterprise level
network but it does it without really
requiring any kind of public key at all
so it does it all with symmetric
encryption so it is inherently very
robust to any kind of quantum computer
so Kerberos was invented in the 70s at
MIT and it's still maintained by MIT but
obviously in recent years you know
variants have it ever appeared in things
like Windows Active Directory I'm just
going to talk sort of in general about
Kerberos I'll try and draw attention to
the differences between you know the
active directory version but mostly its
naming differences really it's what
we're concerned with one of the issues
if we're going to use only symmetric
encryption is we have to work out how to
share keys we can't do key exchange
because that's public key we can't
verify people using something like
certificates because that's RSA that's
public key so what do we do well one of
the ways we can share keys is using
passwords and so we could derive a key I
could take my password I could hash it
in some known way and then we could you
could do the same thing
if you were server but knew my password
or knew the hash and we could have a
shared secret that way so okay let's say
we want to do this right well now let's
think about the number of machines on a
standard corporate network like maybe
there's 2,000 laptops on any given day
connect to the network and 10,000
desktops and 200 servers how many of
these passwords are we using are they
all shared are you what different
passwords different keys I mean let's
use a very simple example let's imagine
we have a network with ten machines so
I'm just going to draw ten machines I
should have drawn fewer machines let's
you know what I can undo this I can say
five machines now if I want to have a
shared key but it's let's say different
for security reasons between all of
these machines it's going to look
something like I think that's all of
them right and then if I add another
machine a SiC machine here I've got to
do this and 1/7 machine this is an
absolute mess right because we can't do
key exchange so normally what you would
do on the internet is you would just
talk to a machine do a quick key
exchange and then you've got yourself a
session key for the rest of that
conversation we can't do that because
that's a public key protocol which is
vulnerable to things like quantum write
and also actually at a time I don't
think if you help me existed when this
was first developed right or at least
the protocols underpinning this so we're
not going to use public key as a
solution we're going to come up with
something different what we're going to
try and do is use the fact that we have
this server which I'm going to draw sort
of nice and big here server a big s on
it like the Superman
this server we all trust and because we
all trust that server we can use that to
give us temporary keys so in orange I'm
going to draw let's imagine that these
machines now have long term keys with
this server all right so there's now one
two three four five seven keys there's
seven permanent keys probably based off
passwords right with this server we will
trust a server for now so that's good
now let's imagine that this machine
wants to talk to this machine what we do
is we ask for server to send us a key
that we can use for that conversation
and it just generates one at random and
protects it using these encrypted
channels and then we can temporarily use
this green key for our session so the
key exchange is now using this trusted
third party so this is kind of what curb
is about it has the benefit but it
doesn't rely on public key but also
there's an inherently there's a really
elegant way but it authenticates you
because basically you can't talk between
these two machines
unless this has given you a key to do it
which is in some sense giving you
permission to do it if this is a file
server and you want to access a file
server it's only going to work if you've
got a key from here and if it doesn't
give you one because you're not allowed
good luck getting onto the file server
alright that's the idea so it's quite a
neat trick but but gets around just
using symmetric and has this
authentication built in now Kerr boss is
also a little bit more complicated than
this so that's what we're going to delve
into now we're going to be on a
fictitious network now and this is me
over here now you know as you know from
my previous videos I'm very good at
drawing computers and they always look
realistic so this is my little desktop
so this is me I'm going to be a a for
Alice or you know and here we have our
authentication our ticket granting
service now these are part of kerb loss
we're gonna have a big machine over here
and this is going to have two servers in
it or two services now in the original
curb loss this would be called a key
distribution center or KDC often this
role is performed by something called a
domain controller on Active Directory
now in here we have two kinds of servers
we have our authentication server which
I'm going to call s and our ticket
granting server which I'm going to call
T and everything to do with
authentication and connecting to a like
an Active Directory or any other kind of
curb or setup is going to be using these
two services so the authentication
server is going to be responsible for
checking your password essentially and
making sure you actually do have an
account on that directory or that
network and the ticket granting server
is going to be responsible for issuing
you tickets which you can use to go and
access things like file servers or
printers or whatever else it is on the
network the first thing to do is to
approach for your fent occasion server
assuming we've already had an account
created and send them a message so we're
gonna send them a message which says my
name is a I would like to talk to the
ticket granting server and here is a
random number that I'm going to use to
prevent replay attacks we're not going
to worry too much about them which is
going to pass them back and forth but
the point is I'm sending a message not
really necessarily encrypted to this
authentication so
the IMA and I'd like to talk to a ticket
granting server now the important thing
here is assuming that a has an account
it has a established key between a and s
I have a key a s which I can use to talk
to that server for the long term because
it's based on my past or it may be I
only change my password every 12 months
or whatever right my passwords very good
I don't have to change it I should I
should tighten notice now so I'm gonna
send this message across to s now s is
going to reply s is going to send a
message which is encrypted assuming it
allows me to talk to T it's going to
send me some messages that mean I can
then talk to T all right so the first
one is going to be here's a key K 80
that you can use to talk between these
two here's your nonce back again to
prevent replay attacks this is the
current time this is the lifetime of
this ticket and you're okay to talk to
the ticket granting server so it just
has a lot of different parts to this
message the things to bear in mind are
so the timestamp I'm a lifetime or
Soviet you can't like hold on to a
ticket for sort of two years and play it
again no and you know we have the names
of things in there to make sure everyone
knows who it is they're supposed to be
talking to so the important thing in
this message is this key K 80 well I'm
using 80 to symbolize this as a session
key between a and T right now I don't
have a long term key with T my computer
doesn't have that this is generated on
the fly by this server now this is
encrypted this message because we can't
be sending keys over the internet if it
are not encrypted so this is going to be
encrypted with my very well drawn curly
brackets and this is going to be
encrypted using K a s which is of course
our long term key between a and the
authentication server what I can do now
is I can decrypt this message using Kas
because that's derived off my password I
can read this session key and then I can
use it to talk to T the problem is that
T doesn't have this session key I this
is new this is brand new this key so
it's going to send s is going to send me
some more information it's going to send
me the same k80
it's going to say this is to talk to a
and this is the lifetime of that ticket
and this is going to be encrypted with K
s T so this the authentication
s is going to use a long term key s T to
encrypt this message which I can't lead
right because I don't have s T I'm ma
right so this is a ticket that I can
pass to T for it to use and only it can
understand so this is called a
wonderfully named ticket granting ticket
it's a ticket that's gonna let me get
more tickets in the future hey so I take
this first message I decrypt it and I
have the session key that I need I
forward this message on to the ticket
granting server it decrypts it and
assuming it's okay it now has the
message but it needs that's kind of cool
this is all the other really nice thing
about this is but it's fire-and-forget
so this authentication server can very
quickly look me up in database fireback
these two new session key is encrypted
and then it's done its work is done
right it's authenticated me that's the
end of the discussion
it doesn't need to talk to me anymore
until I love on another time so the next
thing I have to do or I want to talk to
some kind of server file server let's
say called B now we can't do that yet
because we haven't got a ticket and in
that ticket is going to be a new session
key that we can use to encrypt that
conversation so I'm going to send a
message I'm going to use my purple again
a kind of I've kind of messed up the
colors we'll do our best
all right so I'm going to send a message
now to tea and that's gonna be first of
all this ticket and that ticket says OMA
and this is my new session key that we
can use and this has kind of been
stamped as it were it's been
authenticated by the fact that it's
encrypted by K s T which is the
authentication servers private key with
this T here so I'm gonna send my name is
a this is a timestamp to make sure
everything is taking place at the right
time I'd like to talk to be please and
this is some new random number that
we're going to use to prevent replay
attacks and this is all going to be
encrypted using the K 80 session key
we've just obtained it's okay 80 so only
me and T can read that and I have to
take this and I also forward on the
ticket it decrypts the ticket and now it
has access to k80 and can read my
message right and no one else can this
is why Kerr bosses are clever and so
this ticket granting server is going to
look at me and it's good
at my account and it's going to look at
what B is and work out whether it is
okay that I actually talk to be right
now assuming that's the case it's gonna
respond right it's gonna send me back
let's go with green for this one I don't
know it's going to do exactly the same
as the authentication services so it's
going to produce me a new random key to
be used to talk to be I which we're
going to call kab so we're not gonna get
super confused it's okay
a B and we're going to reply with the
random number as well to prevent me
player tax this is the timestamp of the
server this is the lifetime of this
ticket and finally I would like you to
talk to B and of course this is going to
be encrypted using our key between a and
T okay a t
only since everyone think messages are
encrypted with their own session key or
their own long-term key depending on
which one you're talking to and of
course what else does it need to send
well we need B to be able to have this
kab in order to have a conversation so
it's going to have to send another
ticket to let us access B so this is
going to have K a B right so that's our
shared secret this is I would like you
to talk to a this is of a lifetime this
is going to be encrypted with a key
the only T and B have right which is K
BT
so that will be some password or other
sort of long-term key between this file
server B and our ticket granting server
our key distribution center now we need
to talk to be right so I'm gonna I don't
know let's let's ER list will be over
here so this is our file server B this
is B that's a rack server and it's the
worst rack server I've ever seen
B is just sitting on my network waiting
for thing people to talk to it right and
I come along it gets very excited I'm
gonna forward on the ticket right
because that's the one that it can
decrypt it uses its long term key B T to
decrypt this and now it has access to
this session key it also in some sense
has a proof that I'm allowed to talk to
be because otherwise I wouldn't have
been able to produce his ticket because
this was encrypted by a ticket granting
server a bit like how a digital
signature on the internet might provide
some sort of proof of authenticity this
kind of has that role
I wouldn't even have to produce his
ticket if the ticket granting server
hadn't encrypted it for me to pass on so
I pass on a ticket and I also pass on a
message that says very simply my name is
a this is a kind time and I'm going to
encrypt this using K a B which is the
new key I just got given by a ticket
granting server so I send it that I also
send it per ticket it decrypts the
ticket looks at kab and it can now
understand this message and finally it
responds with my timestamp +1 as a
challenge to prove that it can actually
understand the message and it's not an
impostor and that's going to be also
encrypted with K a B so I've used the
ticket from a ticket granting server to
talk to B and now I can then continue
using that ticket for a while and
continue encryption with B right and
then we can start to send files back and
forth and things like that so let's sort
of look one more time at what what's
going on here right I wanted to talk to
B and I also wanted to authenticate to
this network because this network is
let's say my University Network and I
wanted to log in and all I have at the
moment is a password so what I do is I
send a message to the authentication
server that says I'm a and I'd like to
talk to the ticket granting server it
sends me back an encrypted message that
I would not be able to read if I didn't
have my password so that's how it
authenticates me and it also crucially
sends me a ticket but I can use to pass
on to the ticket granting server these
two things both contain a new session
key that I can use for encryption so
then I talk to the ticket granting
server and the exact same process
happens again I say I'm a I'd like to
talk to B B's a file server the ticket
granting server will look at the s it
will look at the what B is and decide ok
he is allowed to access this server so
it will send me back a message with a
new key and it will also send me back a
ticket to pass on to B so it's the exact
same process so every time I want to
talk to anything on this network I can
just go to the ticket granting server
with my ticket and say please may I have
another one for this and it will give me
new tickets so I can just go and get
tickets it's like like an affair ground
and you know you've got a lot of Ferris
wheel and other stuff and you just go to
one desk to buy all the tickets and then
you can go to the actual rides later or
something like that
that kind of idea so I then can talk to
B and we have this little exchange that
makes sure that you know there's no me
player tax and you know we're not doing
anything untoward so it's a really neat
way of just using symmetric encryption
to gain actually some pretty good
security these tickets how long does it
last so it depends on a ticket but on
authentication ticket like the one you
get on the ticket granting ticket right
from from s that could last 24 hours or
something like that
now tell it where it's going where it's
come from and then these days the local
network almost certain